foreign
they say it's an alliance Without Limits
China and Russia are expanding trade and
diplomatic cooperation
the two countries insist their relations
are far from being a military and
political Alliance
but Qi jumping and Vladimir Putin share
a growing concern of what they perceive
to be an American dominance across the
globe
for the Chinese leader who secured an
unprecedented third term earlier this
month this trip could be the moment to
establish his country as an
international Peacemaker
we shall always respect and abide by the
U.N Charter we will always promote peace
and also promote negotiation and
discussion our stance is always based on
fairness and Justice we will always be
on the side of Peace we are always on
the side of dialogue we are always on
the side of historic fairness and
justice
but ending war in Ukraine may not be an
easy task China is yet to elaborate on
its 12 point peace plan
Beijing has called on Russia and Ukraine
to address their security concerns
without mentioning Russian troops
withdrawal a key demand for Kiev
the US has dismissed the peace plan as a
stalling tactic in the meantime Western
nations are stepping up military
assistance to Ukraine
ministers today we learned that the
minister of defense of the UK declared
he would Supply tanks to the Ukraine and
also uranium enriched weapons to Ukraine
I think that the West will now fight
Russia to the last Ukrainian
facing growing International isolation
Vladimir Putin is turning to president
Xi Jinping an alliance largely shaped
following Russian invasion of Ukraine
last year
after the EU imposed a ban on Russian
energy Imports China stepped in buying
large quantities of cheap Russian oil
providing cash-wrapped Moscow with much
needed Revenue
the U.S considers China the biggest
threat to its National Security and
fears Beijing could be exploiting
Russia's in battle standing to expand
its geopolitical influence